دانت حركه حماس زيارتها وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي الى الخرطوم امس الخميس الحركه
رات ان قرار القياده السودانيه بشان
التطبيع مع اسرائيل خروج عن موقف الشعب
السوداني التاريخي الرافضي لنهج التطبيع
ودعت حماس الخرطوم الى العدول عن قرارها
الذي قالت انه يتزامن مع تصعيد الاحتلال
لاعتداءاته على الفلسطينيين وسيوفر له
الغطاء لارتكاب المزيد من الجرائم
والانتهاكات بحقهم واثقه تعبيرها بدورها
ادانه الجبهه الشعبيه استقبال البرهان
لوزير خارجيه الاحتلال ودعت الشعب
السودانيه بقواه المختلفه الى التصدي لما
وصفته خيانه نظام البرهان قائله ان
التطبيع سيلحق الضرر بمصالح الشعب
السوداني على حد تعبيرها
هذا وقد نفى نائب رئيس مجلس السياده محمد
حمدان حميدتي علمه بزياره الوفد
الاسرائيلي واكد انه لم يلتقي به في حين
قالت رابطه اعلاميون من اجل القدس ان
الحكومه الانتقاليه لا تملك حق التوقيع
على اي اتفاق مع اسرائيل وقال المؤتمر
الشعبي ان الغرض من محاوله التطبيع
اليائسه وان يظل السودان تحت حكم العسكر
بدعم من العدو الاسرائيلي واضاف ان محاوله
التطبيع لا يكتب لها النجاح مهما تكاثرت
وقدمت لها وعود الترغيب والترهيب حسب
تعبيره جانبه شدد التيار الاسلامي العريض
على رفض ما يجري الان من تعقيدات في
المشهد السياسي السوداني لانها صنعت خصيصا
لتمرير هذه الصفقات الفاسده بحسب تعبيره
كما قال تجمع المهنيين السودانيين انما
وصفه بالنظام الانقلابي لن تنقذه
الاتفاقات مع الاعداء ولا التحالفات
المشبوهه